l'arrosage ici c'est zéro dans le jardin
en 11 ans maintenant il y a eu quatre
arrosoirs de distribués j'ai planté
celui-ci je crois que c'est un pied que
j'ai dû acheter pratiquement tous les
autres c'est des boutures ben regarde la
pivoine tu as plein de gens qui me
disent mais on peut on dit toujours
obligé de désherber parce que sinon les
plantes elles se font concurrence elles
se font chier se font ça tu as déjà vu
la nature
[Musique]
c'est histoire d'un mec qu'on a marre
qu'on lui dise que c'est pas possible
qu'on a marre de voir les gens faire de
la merde parce que ils disent que c'est
pas possible que c'est pas possible
parce qu'on n'a pas le pognon parce
qu'on n'a pas le temps parce qu'on n'a
pas le personnel parce qu'on a pas les
connaissances je veux que ce jardin soit
en élargissement du champ des possibles
et pour l'instant ça marche plutôt pas
mal
[Musique]
tu as la première fleur de pitchen Rise
tu vois le nénuphar qui est là-bas mais
c'est une tuerie cette fleur j'espère
que le ragondin va pas tous me les
flinguer ce jardin est fait pour ça
aussi c'est pour montrer que tu peux
faire autrement qu'avec des pognon pour
faire un jardin qui soit spectaculaire
parce que je pense qu'il est un peu
spectaculaire malgré tout et avec un
temps de travail qui doit correspondre à
en ce qui me concerne actuellement c'est
5 jours de travail par an pour
l'entretien c'est un lieu qui a des
fonctions très précises accueil de
biodiversité maximum faible entretien
impact écologique le plus positif
possible et donner envie à des gens qui
ont le pouvoir de faire différemment de
faire différemment elle est sous forme
de fruits c'est quand elle est en fleur
qu'elle est fabuleuse c'est la
fritillière œuf de pintade
avec un peu de chance elles vont se
remettre et que les prochaines années on
aura carrément un tapis de ça peut-être
dans 10 ans c'est un jardin qui est
vachement immersif tu amènes quelqu'un
là il va toujours trouver un endroit où
il se sent bien je sais qu'il y a plein
de gens qui adorent passer sous ses
boulots tu vois
j'aime bien ici j'avoue regarde dans
quoi ça pousse tout ça
là ça fait trois semaines qu'il a pas
plu
voilà
ça marche
le truc elle est blanche il y a pas il y
a que dalle non mais c'est l'ensemble
qui se stimule les herbes qui vont faire
des racines qui vont profiter aux arbres
qui vont les racines des armes profiter
certaines herbes les branches mortes qui
tombent petit à petit elle crée de
l'humus en surface
une partie des fleurs quand les fleurs
vont tomber ça fait de la matière
organique en grande grande quantité par
contre si tu as besoin de faire pousser
ta bouffe c'est autre chose là ici tu es
au flerial il y a quelques végétaux
fruitiers nourriciers qui peuvent
subvenir à une toute petite partie de
tes besoins mais si tu devais dépendre
de ça c'est pas adapté c'est quoi la
définition du jardin Punk est d'où ça
vient j'ai pas inventé jardin punk j'ai
défini c'est complètement différent à
plein de gens qui faisaient des jardins
qui savaient pas qu'ils disaient les
jardins punk et moi non plus avant que
j'écrive jardin punk
l'idée c'est comment est-ce qu'on peut
faire en faisant le moins possible
tu as vu les copines elles sont là
ça tu vois je gère pas ça je maîtrise
pas je les ai pas implantés mais quel
bonheur
trop bien tu vois par exemple ça là j'ai
planté quelques petites plantes la fleur
de coucou ça s'appelle les Knis le
coucou lit la blanche fait une sélection
horticole que j'avais à la pépinière
j'en ai planté deux trois pots et
maintenant sur disséminine partout parce
que le milieu l'aurait hyper propice
là ton travail c'est limité à quoi sur
ce rosier empêcher qui m'empêche de
passer
c'est exactement tout ce que je fais
pour lui
c'est nouveau ça
tu vois les arbres grandissent donc on
commence à accueillir de nouvelles
populations d'oiseaux c'est la première
fois que je vois autant de tournoi ici
tous les boulots
ils étaient gros comme ça voilà
il y a 11 ans
quand les mots viennent là que je leur
demande d'estimer l'âge des arbres on a
tout et n'importe quoi des fois il doit
avoir moins 70 ans sinon ils ont votre
âge
et ça les avoir planté tout petit bah
ils sont développés vachement mieux
j'ai regardé le terrain pendant pendant
un an je suis allé voir les alentours je
regardais ce qui poussait spontanément
ou pas j'ai regardé comment évoluer
d'autres champs qui avait été abandonné
ou pas et à partir de ça j'ai fait mon
dessin en envisageant tous mes besoins
toutes mes envies les nécessités
donc ouais j'ai créé des grandes lignes
toutes les allées sont tendues à la
tondeuse le reste la prairie n'est
jamais fauché intégralement donc j'évite
par exemple que mes voisins est trop de
chardons si j'ai pas envie qu'ils
mettent encore plus de produits
chimiques dans leur champ donc quand les
chardons ont fini de fleurir ceux qui
sont les plus près du champ
comme ça et les ronces pareil
j'ai pas d'ennemis mais en fait l'un de
mes objectifs ici et de conserver la la
prairie au maximum si je fais rien ça
devient un bois
le champ quand je l'ai acheté c'était
recouvert de ça rumex et puis de chardon
avec un petit peu de graminées d'autres
choses
ça sera saine bien ça regarde la belle
fleur ça passe à l'image ça
et père vierge
comme un épervier
des fois au jardin il y a des gens qui
viennent et puis qui veulent un petit
peu me piquer au livre donc en fait il
vous faut tirer dans votre jardin c'est
un peu facile
vous laissez juste pousser et là je les
emmène ici je remonte là vous voyez
quand je laisse tout faire c'est ça
là-bas il y a un taillis impénétrable
d'arbres qui font 6 ou 8 mètres de haut
ça c'est quand on fait rien sur le même
terrain ça va rappelle que en faisant
très peu finalement on transforme déjà
beaucoup le milieu et on arrive à avoir
des bons résultats et ça laisse aussi
imaginer à quel point on peut [__] le
bordel quand on agit plus
[Musique]